[Music]
[Applause]
luna the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin if you're just getting into
crypto it's the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
punch show joining me today as you can
see is the president and co-founder of
silica i'm rit kumar i'm rick welcome to
the show how are you thank you very much
for inviting me over yeah i'm doing good
yourself you okay
i'm doing good yeah it's good to chat to
you i think the last time we spoke was
maybe
back in september 2019 in london before
covid i think that's when it was
right indeed you know a lot of things
have happened since
since that meet-up i guess um you know
in the world and of course in silica as
well
oh yeah absolutely that's right before
the good old pandemic kicked off but
before we jump in um i do want to let
everybody know that this is powered by
um icon plus capital they're a vc firm
and it is sponsored by block five so
they offer really incredible interest
rates really competitive interest rates
so i think i've left a link somewhere so
you can you can check that out if you're
interested so let's jump into this this
is going to be a really exciting ama
like i said we haven't spoken in nearly
two years
so
for me this is going to be really
educational um but i think what would be
great would be to start off sort of
understanding a little bit more about
you so tell me your background before
you delved into crypto
right so uh my background is in research
so before joining and getting involved
into crypto i was doing scientific
research around security and privacy so
essentially i was looking into
ways in which you'd
you know when you download a certain
software systems like let's say
antivirus software on a machine
what sort of security and privacy
implications they have on your system so
for example
an antivirus may scan your entire file
system they can scan all the photos or
files that you may have and me send some
information you know to the backend
vendor so the antivirus
so the idea was to sort of understand
what sort of information they do send
and why they have to send that
information
so this was uh you know early 2016 i
would say and around that time you know
bitcoin and blockchains generally
speaking were becoming popular you know
in the academic circle
yeah people were starting to see bitcoin
as not just a technology but as a place
where you could find and discover
interesting challenging research
problems as well
so that was around the time when you
know that peaked my interest as well so
i was looking into i started to feel
that okay now i have to switch over to
blockchains so i moved over to uh to
singapore where i decided to look into
the privacy aspects of blockchains so as
you know transact on bitcoin or ethereum
everything that you do becomes public so
anyone can see what happens on those
chains
there there were some privacy chains
like dash monero zcash that had come up
which can hide some of the traces of
your activity that happens on the
blockchain but my idea was to sort of
look into those uh privacy preserving
blockchains and see whether you actually
get that privacy in practice or not
strangely though
since the start of monero
and until early 2017
95 to 98 percent of transactions that
ever happened on monero were not private
at all so you could actually decipher a
lot of information from oh wow just by
looking at the blockchain
that's not good so you know very soon
afterwards uh you know my advisor who
was at the university back then um
he said look this was good fun let's
look at something more challenging after
this
and around that time we had seen crypto
kitties happen uh
where an icos were happening so this was
you know mid 2017 around that time
and we realized that obviously the these
technologies that we have around bitcoin
ethereum they are really good they're
very decentralized
but they're not very scalable
and therefore the idea that we had was
to be able to build a blockchain that
could scale and that's how you know
you know silica sort of came into being
uh you know something somewhere some
sometime around mid-2017 so that's kind
of my background my story
so if you had to i guess summarize in a
really simplistic way you know what is
silica okay so scalability is obviously
um you know at the core there but if you
could summarize it
and tell us a little bit more
right so the two when we started silica
we had two key problems i wanted to
address one was of course scalability so
we had seen you know
ethereum sort of plug every time there
was an ico you couldn't transact on
ethereum gas fees went really high
to a point where if you wanted to set a
transaction worth five dollars you have
to pay a hundred dollars worth of fees
so it was it was around that time that
we had started to look into scalability
and the solution that we came up with uh
was called sharding what is called
sharding it's an idea where which is
something that you now see many of the
chains sort of pursuing as well but we
were the first ones
to show that you could actually apply
this idea of sharding in a public
blockchain like silica
so um that was kind of our one usb the
second problem that we sort of
identified was
this idea where you could have
smart contracts that are so expressive
that they invite a lot of attacks and we
have seen that happen every other week
you know we have seen starting from dao
for example when
uh you know there was uh you know the
entire ethereum community sort of kind
of got divided into ethereum ethereum
classic we saw parity incident happen we
saw
very recently you know some of the hacks
are on ed5 it was very clear to us very
in the early days that uh you can't just
wait and watch you need to be able to
build solutions that could prevent if
not eliminate completely at least you
know mitigate some of those
hacks that you see on a daily basis
so we decided to collaborate with some
of the academics in uh in london by the
way
uh so we had an academic from ucl london
and the idea was to be able to develop a
language
that could eliminate some of those hacks
from happening in the future
so we decided this we decided to design
a new language that we call cila with
the idea of
making the language
more resistant to attacks and at the
same time you could actually
make it even more stronger you could
even say that look if you have a
contract
that holds let's say i don't know a
billion dollars you want to make sure
that no one can come in and steal funds
from that contract no one can freeze
that money
and what you need essentially is a
mathematical proof that could say that
okay here's a guarantee and my guarantee
is that it you cannot break it it's a
there's a mathematical proof behind it
and languages like cilla um allows you
to do that in a much easier way
with solidity even if you try to do that
it's much more complex so the idea was
to be able to design a language that's
saved by design at the same time it
gives you some stronger properties
that's very hard to prove so yeah these
are kind of two key areas that you
already focus on scalability and and
smart contract safety
yeah i think especially it's interesting
actually to have this conversation now
especially given how much this space has
developed since our initial conversation
you know
there's other blockchains out there and
we'll talk about that in terms of
competitors you know like cardano for
example also working with smart
contracts um so yeah we're going to go
into all of this and i'm really excited
to actually um but i want to start off
with the ama now because there are some
really interesting questions and one of
the first questions actually came
through on twitter um i'm considering
whether to try and pronounce these names
but i'm going to put it on pause with a
minute
um so our first question is so when is
the bridge finally going to launch on
the mainnet
right so um as you know um we and those
those people who are following us um we
have been using polynetwork which is the
middleware
for bridges unfortunately middleware got
hacked recently
which means that we have to be very
careful about how we use that middleware
polynet has been fixing these issues but
it's not fully open in the sense that
they have not fully opened up their
middleware to everyone to use so they're
still you know playing very carefully
and we are basically waiting for them to
one open up
at the same time you're also taking
other precautionary measures measures
making sure that you know that incident
cannot happen again uh you know with
silica uh community
so we're also sort of sort of hardening
our systems to make sure that those
hacks and bugs cannot happen
we are also sort of reaching out to
white hat sort of hackers as well
through hacker one
and basically throwing them the code and
say okay just go and hack it
uh the difference between hackers and
auditors is that auditors generally try
to sort of check whether your contract
follows a certain pattern
checks whether they check whether it
follows a certain
security recommendations in some sort so
they have a checklist that you try to go
with
well hackers have you know basically a
launch of some sort where they
they go and basically try to hack your
system which is which can sometimes be
very productive because if you want to
want to find bugs so we are doing that
at the same time we are literally you
know i think today started to prepare
our main net for an upgrade that upgrade
is necessary to be able to enable
polynet
so i think in a week's time we will be
able to have um uh all the features
ready to have uh to be on the main it
and after that we are basically waiting
for the polly net uh and some of the
hackers to come back to us uh and once
all is done and dusted um there's
nothing left to open up the network for
for the bridge
and given what happened with polynetwork
how
did that directly affect you in any way
can we hear more about that no actually
we didn't because uh and we were kind of
lucky to be honest because um our bridge
was not live yet
even if it had been live then it would
have been different story luckily it was
not live and therefore we were saved in
many ways uh which i think we're yeah it
was basically lucky
and that's why you know we have to be
careful of uh how to how to employ that
uh once it goes live so we have to make
sure that the system is hardened uh poly
network uh whatever the code changes
that they're making they have to get
that code audio test as well so peck
shield for example one of the auditors
have checked some of the code they are
also talking to other auditors they're
taking sort of very
gradual approach of releasing polynet to
other people as well so we are sort of
following their steps and at the same
time on our end we are making sure that
the contracts that we have written are
safe to use and you know getting other
people to to to to sort of check the
code again and again but basically it's
we are very close um it's all about sort
of preparing the mainnet with all the
features and then once uh auditors and
once um these hackers give us some
feedback then we could launch this
and once you do launch is the team
working on bringing projects that are
currently you know building on ethereum
um to move over to zil i know during the
bull market we massively saw that happen
with um finance smart chain which was
really interesting um you know they
really became kind of like a die rice
competitor in some ways so are you guys
looking to kind of do the same thing
right so the first thing that happens is
so buying a smart chain and silica is
slightly different in the sense that
binding smart chain is an evm compatible
chain which means that uh if let's say
if you have a contract that's sitting on
a theorem you could basically copy paste
that and put that
one smart changes could still work
um silica is not an evm compatible
change it means that it's uh and for
good reasons uh in the sense that you
know we have seen what's happening with
solidity code so we have to be careful
about building a building a safer smart
contract language and making sure that
that doesn't happen and replicate
so but what what can happen is obviously
once the bridge is live you'll be able
to move assets like usdt btc eth over to
silica and then put that on zilswap and
once uh your assets are swap you can
start earning apy depending on you know
the the total value log that stay on
that on that pool
once those assets are over to silica
they could also be used in different d5
products that we already have on zelika
for example uh there's a pillar protocol
that's being built which is a maker dial
like system on silica and you could use
for example btc and eth as or usdt for
example as one of the collaterals
or for pillar
there are other assets that are other d5
products that are being built and i
think this is where these assets can
come into play uh to be honest it's not
going to be so straightforward for
people to just move from
from ethereum to silica but there is
going to be a little bit of work and and
i feel that that work is worth doing it
given
all the hacks that are happening in the
d5 and empty space nft space less so but
d5 differently so so we have to be
careful about what you bring you don't
want to bring things that are already
buggy and you have to be careful with
that
uh and i i feel that it's it's all about
making sure that um
you know when these assets come over we
need to have applications that can use
those assets and that's very critical
this is where for example has a protocol
slight pillar will be will play a key
role
speaking of pillar um one of the
questions that i've come through which
is actually pretty interesting is
somebody is claiming that the pillar
protocol project has gone quiet
um so do you have any updates on that is
it still going to launch
well they are quiet only because i think
they are developing so they are quite
what's going on behind the scenes
um what i know is that again this is a
this is a project that's not developed
by us it's being developed by committee
member
and uh which has given which has
received a grant from us
and uh what i know is that they again
they are very careful about uh you know
launching this uh
this product making sure that it's safe
to you for people to use so they have
done a round of audit i know that they
are uh have literally i think a couple
of days ago i had mentioned in one of
the telegram channels that
they have launched and finished
a mechanism where you could use gso
which is our governance token to govern
uh decisions around pillar so for
example which collateral which type of
collateral can be used on pillar
and people who who come and use their
gcl for for governance on pillar would
also have an incentive to participate so
you would be also be earning a part of
the rewards that comes from pillar which
essentially the interest rate so when
you come and take loan from pillar when
you borrow assets
you will have to
you know return interest rate and a
portion of that interest rate could go
back to the people who help govern the
system so yes it's fully it's it's
working uh you know they have already
launched i think the version three it's
not publicly available to people but
they are working behind the scenes so
though it's it's more like the you know
silently working on what's happening and
hopefully they will be able to open this
up uh hopefully very soon to to to the
rest of the community
good well at least uh
things are still moving forward which we
always like to hear um okay so i yeah i
want i do want to talk about the
competition in the market um and one of
the questions is actually comparing
zilliqa to cardano i know you spoke
about this a bit earlier um i'll read
you the question so silica have many
more use cases than cardinal at the
moment obviously gibbon cardano hasn't
essentially launched has it so
has a zilliqa team done any research on
why zil may be undervalued in the market
compared to cardano and what measures
can be done to overcome this
so
i mean would you say that zil is
undervalued in comparison to ada
well everything is under valued ideas
you would never say you say that okay
here's a theorem of bitcoin is it's
overvalued you won't see that
everything's gone obviously i do feel
that we're undervalued um
but you know um if you look at uh
the projects that existed let's say in
early 2017 uh
in the top 10 or top 20. many of them
don't exist anymore uh many of them have
slid down into oblivion
it's all about making sure that so these
these uh you know market sentiments they
keep up and down you know they keep your
ranking or your price can keep moving up
and down there's something that you
cannot control per se what you can
control is is the develop and innovation
component
so as long as you keep building
interesting stuff as long as you keep
attracting
uh more projects and you keep attracting
more users to the platform there's no
reason why your the market can can stay
you know oblivious to what you're
building at some point it will come out
and that's happened right you know many
projects that uh have been building uh
quite aggressively over the last couple
of years they didn't exist
uh in top ten top 3 today you know the
top 20 of today is very different from
the top 20 that existed a year ago or
something six months ago so that that
that will definitely happen as long as
we make sure that a lot of people
actually come and use the platform and
the project that we're building and
again we're very early stage you know
it's not just zelika but i think
generally speaking
blockchain is a very early stage of
adoption right
you look at and i keep citing this
million times and i will repeat this
again
but if you look at the number of token
holders that you have out there or just
for ethereum for example there are
around
a few hundred million uh 140 million i
think uh ethereum token
i didn't know that use
is is actually less than less than a
million or around two million so you can
see the gap between
number of token holders the number of
users i think it's important for every
blockchain platform to push for that is
to make sure that we can attract more
convert more of these token holders into
actual users of the platform once that
happens you know that network effect
that comes with it uh is something that
you can't you know
the world has to recognize the network
right you can't skip it
i do want to go back just a little bit
um to focus on the polynetwork hack
because i'm actually reading the
questions as they came in um so
this is a pretty interesting question so
um the recent polynetwork incident was
pretty scary i think everyone can agree
um you know i guess it was a good thing
that you know that bridge hadn't
launched yet so hypothetically speaking
could the bridge have been written in
cilla and if so would this type of
vulnerability have been more easily
spotted or even prevented
yes uh so the short answer is yes uh
if if so but there are two components to
it right so yeah the way bridge works is
you have an ethereum component you have
a silica component
so someone who let's say who wants to
move assets from ethereum to silica he
has to send a transaction on the theorem
network first
and then this transaction basically gets
relayed to the silica network and then
uh you know there's a smart contract
that comes into play on the zelica site
essentially what happened was on
ethereum side uh there's solidity code
and it had a component that allowed you
know the hacker to basically
uh do really nasty stuff
if you had replaced that contract by a
very similar looking seller contract
this would not happen you know this
attack would could have been averted but
the problem is it's on ethereum and the
theorem is is you know does not support
cellar so you have only solidity so you
don't have much choice there
i do and that's kind of why i believe
that there's going to be you know you
will have a point in time somewhere in
the future where many of the genes
including silica for example could be uh
sort of multi vm compatible so you could
have you could run solidity you could
run cilla you could run rust you could
run other chain other languages as well
that's where i think some benefit could
have come
even though for example um you know we
have other networks like switcho who
were using and polynet they were not
affected so not every chain was affected
even though they were using it uh should
not would not have been affected for
sure
yes the short answer again is yes if if
solitude contract would have been
replaced with a silla contract uh this
attack uh in a hack would not have
happened but again ethereum uh does not
support sellers so it's not it's not
possible so that nuance is there as well
okay yeah i think covering these things
is really important
i think that hack took a lot of people
by surprise um even to the point where i
actually just read this today but the
news came out yesterday um that i think
the polly network are looking to hire
the hacker
i mean he did i mean okay uh again you
could you could probably question the
intentions or initial intentions of the
hacker and all that you could debate
about yeah but he definitely um some
people could say look um the contract
well this was a very stupid bug uh you
know the developer should have detected
it but it's quite smart to be honest uh
the you know the ability to find some of
those
uh nuanced uh you know lanes in the co
contracts and code it's not so
straightforward so uh credit to the
hacker to be honest um could great to
the hacker to be able to find the find
the bug
and i from what i'm hearing is he has
returned the funds
and i guess um you know pollya guys are
sort of trying to see if um if he could
be helping out in different ways so why
not again you know turning from about
that great hat to white hat uh it's not
so straightforward but um at least it
was interesting to note that
you know he was able to return the fonts
which is which is well yeah
i mean if you can go from black hat to
gray hat to white hat i see no reason i
can't go from white hat to gray hat to
black cat i don't know i'd stay away
from it personally um okay so again we
have more comparisons um
this is also pretty interesting so does
zilliqa have something to actually
counter the api once gzil minting is
over and then i'll quote i mean 12 is
nice but i can reach almost the same
with a stable coin on a few exchanges
which is obviously quite true um i know
ada is around five percent um on the
other hand we can on stake instantly so
how's that gonna look
right so uh one is you know comparing a
stable coin with a volatile asset is i
don't think it's it's a fair comparison
agreed on because okay sure a volatile
asset can go down but it also could go
up
so uh even though you are and the reason
why for example stable coins have a
certain api is because there are for
example if you look at block file you
mentioned right block parts
and some of these traditional
centralized
lending platforms uh if you compare for
example the lending rates on different
assets stable coins comes first so
that could vary from something between
five percent up to 10 15 percent yeah
then you have btc and eth uh
and the apy i mean apy the lending rate
uh
varies something between three percent
two to five percent
and then you go even below on alt coins
uh or erc20s that drops to one percent
or even lower sometimes yeah the reason
is simple it's it's demand because when
you think about it right why stable
coins have higher apy generally speaking
it's because they are traders they are
market makers they are institutions who
want to borrow stable coins to be able
to you know put that into work for
example a market maker would like to
borrow
you know usd or usdc and then use that
to do arbitrage trading on different
exchanges
you could you could have institutions
borrowing or hedge funds borrowing usd
and usdc to be able to invest and take
positions on different assets like btc
and eth and that's why the api is
generally high on stable coins
but then again you don't have the same
upside as for example in investing in a
volatile asset right so even for example
in bitcoin lending if it's three percent
you do have an upside
of potential value you know price
increase that you don't get with stable
points
now coming back to zil's uh comparison
uh of course this is just to say that
you know zelicah is different for
stablecoin and therefore it's not an
apple apples to apple comparison
we do believe that uh 12 in terms of
returns is actually quite high compared
to all staking providers so if you look
at it
many of them uh
offer you something between three
percent to up to five percent seven
percent ten percent max
so in terms of api it's actually quite
high
uh if you add g-cell which is the
governance tokens that we're giving out
alongside staking then i think the api
goes even higher to about 25 percent
um so yes there will be a drop once
diesel uh goes down
uh one once diesel emitting is over but
i think you still feel that only 12 is
high enough
now uh if you compare uh for example
let's say cardano is mentioned in about
five percent with immediate uh and
bonding
this is something that could be possible
because there are projects
out there in the silica ecosystem today
which are building a solution where you
could bypass and bonding and that that
would be possible so you could still
have 12 percent apy and be able to
unstake immediately through some of
those parties some of those products
that are being built
so uh yes i don't think we would be able
to increase that otherwise uh the only
way you could increase apy is by you
know minting and inflating the supply or
increasing the inflation which i think
hurts everyone so it's not a good idea
but yeah there will be solution i think
that people are building solutions where
you couldn't bond immediately
so just to let everybody know that i'm
reading through the comments now and the
live comments um so you guys are welcome
to send through um
any questions we have plenty more to get
through but i'm just taking the time now
just to read through them all so you're
all welcome to yeah add as many
questions as you like
so i'm going to keep going forward with
this um we're going to get a little bit
more technical now so the next question
is don't you think that there is a
problem with decentralizing validation
though since these nodes are centralized
by the large mining pools each mining
pool manages dozens of nodes so
it would be great for decentralization
to find a way to have more nodes for
more users
right so uh again it's uh you know it's
a discussion that you know happens uh
even in the bitcoin community and i
think ethereum committee as well
so you have i would say in zilliqa you
have two types of uh miners uh one
miners are obviously pool operators like
uh easel like shardpool like russ pool
and then you have a lot of individual
miners as well so it's not that they are
not individual miners so they are
individual miners mining
mining silica through the old systems
and machines and
so that's that's that's there
of course you know um decentralization
is always a spectrum right you know it's
not always black and white and say okay
this is the decentralized this is
uh not decentralized so it's always a
spectrum yes um
we could encourage people to be um to be
individual and solo miners
but then sometimes the reward and the
and the uh you know the cost that comes
out with it
is it's not you know and it's not enough
for people to have solar minus so what
people end up doing essentially so if
you have a hardware
and you try to solo mine you won't be
making too much money so what you end up
doing is you end up joining mining pools
so even though mining pool you could
consider them as one single entity they
are actually
they actually have a lot of individual
miners behind them
so that answers a little bit that that
part the other thing that we have been
thinking internally again it's not
something we have acted upon yet
but one idea that we had was um that
we're exploring some time back was to be
able to
have mining plus staking as well in
terms of in terms of
nodes that validate transactions so you
could for example right now
all the nodes which validate
transactions they come through mining
but for example we could do 30 mining or
70 mining 30 staking nodes that that
will allow more nodes uh which are
individual operators to come on board
and
and and and start validating
transactions which probably make things
more decentralized but just to give a
little bit more context right uh if you
look at some of the other chains out
there
which have proof of stake mechanism
none of the chains that out there have
more than let's say a thousand nodes
so and i'm talking about staking nodes
so if you think about
having building a network with let's say
three thousand or ten thousand staking
nodes that's not quite possible because
they're not enough stakers out there
they're not even people out there who
would like to put
run an infrastructure uh and and you
know increase the account to up to two
thousand three thousand the maximum that
i've seen so far is around 900 nodes but
again that's a extreme
so uh hitting 900 nodes with taking it
is going to be very challenging
yeah i can't remember who i was having
this conversation with but i feel like
i'm suddenly having deja vu um which is
really strange uh this conversation
about you know decentralization comes
you know with more people getting on
board more nodes you know more with more
users you can make this happen
essentially um i feel like i'm having
dslv so that's kind of strange but um
yeah it's pretty interesting just off
the back of this mining comment um there
is a question that's just come through
now and
i'd be interested to hear your opinion
on it um this is a pretty hot topic in
this space right now where people are
talking a lot about green energy
and things like that i wondered if you
had any thoughts on this question mining
that's pretty much a statement mining is
very frowned upon in the green community
i wondered if you had any thoughts on
that yeah right so uh there are two
sides of the story of course one is uh
you could argue that many of the uh
mining structure is being run by
non-renewable sources yeah
uh but there are also initiatives where
many of these miners are actually using
renewable sources as well
uh there's also an argument that you
could say that look uh if bitcoin is uh
you know handling this much of
transaction volume on a daily basis
if you compare this with traditional uh
you know infrastructures and banks they
actually consume less so there's that
argument as well but let's keep that
aside for a moment i do feel that yes
uh there is that angle and i think many
people are working towards that so and
that's kind of why proof is taking also
is coming into into play and you know
many chains out there now use profit
stake
um which definitely reduces uh the
carbon uh footprint on the zilliqa side
particularly and we we did understand
this problem you know we knew and
reclaimed this problem a long time back
that's kind of why we decided to not use
mining in the way bitcoin and ethereum
you know mining works so in bitcoin
ethereum um you have to basically do a
proof of work for every single block
right yeah
in zilliqa we don't do that so what we
do is we encourage miners to come in
mine for let's say a minute
and this mining when they do when doing
this money for a minute they basically
get an access an entry ticket to the
network
and once they have the central ticket
they
use uh something called a bfd so
byzantine fault orders mechanism which
does not involve mining at all so it's
pure voting mechanism something that
most pos systems use so our mining
basically is utilized let's say once
every two thousand blocks probably
speaking
uh so roughly every two hours which
reduces the carbon footprint the second
thing that we did was we we used hash
and because we don't use uh proof of
work every single block what you can
basically do is you can mine ethereum or
let's say mines and bitcoin
and when this two minute block slot
comes in you come and start mining
silica and then go back
so your your hardware basically you can
basically do parallel mining of some
sort so you could mine silica and
ethereum in parallel
while only spending a minute of your
hardware on silica that's it so it also
makes things much more efficient okay
that's really interesting yeah no i
appreciate you explaining that it's such
a hot topic right now and um
you know there's a lot of misinformation
out there um especially you know when we
talk about renewable energy and
and things like that so i think it's
really important to go through through
those topics just moving on um are there
any plans for um the zeal networks be
accepted by your partner crypto.com
since there aren't yet other stable
coins on the zilliqa network and this
user says i don't like to pay each fees
to use xsgd thank you
uh yes so uh there's there's a plan but
i think there are certain regulation uh
regulatory changes that are happening in
in singapore right now from where
execute which is a stable coin singapore
dollar backstable coin so until that
regulatory uh you know uncertainty are
cleared uh i think it might be a little
bit difficult for parties in singapore
to to list those assets but yes it's
happening and i think
that might come very soon
so we're just going to keep moving
forward um guys please you are welcome
to continue putting questions in the
live chat i am monitoring it so yeah
feel free to throw them in um all right
so i'm going to keep moving forward so
we have our next question this one is
from jerome lin
so see i will i will name some of the
names um okay so this one says since
zilliqa prides itself to be safe and
secure and build a programming language
from the ground up why are we not doing
the same thing for our foundation d5
exchanges as well as our
interoperability instead of relying on
third-party networks to help us build it
because the first thing we can't build
everything right you know yeah it's like
it's like ethereum foundation building
uni swap ethereum foundation building
maker diet same foundation building
synthetics ethereum foundation building
curve and and so on so it's it's not
possible realistically speaking what i
what we do however is and so from from
our angle essentially we're a platform
right so we we provide the platform that
we encourage in different ways uh one
from through marketing developer
workshops uh as well as funding to
encourage other parties to come and
build
um and that's why for example we have
seen uh switcho in which uh to whom we
gave a grant long time back and through
that partnership we had we switched was
interested in building uh
building a decks uh we for example we
gave grants to uh to parties like
mintable which decided to build a nft
marketplace uh we gave grants to people
like pillar protocol which decided to
build a maker like like system so we
give grant so that other people can
build because not everything can be
built by us
same for uh poly data extends super data
as well because again yes we could have
built this whole system ourselves but
then it would have taken much longer it
would have taken uh we have taken much
more risk and then if we had a party
that um again on it is a unfortunately
it came in a bad state right now because
of the hack but they were
one of the parties that had the right
middleware that could essentially plug
in plug and play and that made life
simpler for everyone so again if not
polygon it would be some someone else
it's like
why not go and build a chain link
infrastructure yes you could go and
build a chain link infrastructure but
if there's something that already
available why not just plug into that to
make your life easier and so that you
could focus on some things that are much
more important
from our side our goal has been to
sort of seed projects or insert
ourselves into projects that can
potentially create tentacles for example
once we
when we gave grants to uh switcho the
idea was to have decks and once we had
the decks
very clearly and very soon after what we
saw afterwards we saw 20 odd projects
launching on sale swap so that's kind of
our role our role is to plant seeds the
right seats at the right place so that
others can hopefully build things around
that
but yeah we can't build everything
ourselves that's not
in the same way theme foundation could
not have built everything that's being
built on ethereum today themselves that
is that is something that you can't do
no absolutely um you know but a lot of
people are building a lot of similar
things you know whether it's you know d5
protocols you know sushi swap pancake
swap um you know everything we've spoken
about and mentioned so
our final well it's not a final question
but one of the the the last questions
from joshua wilford is what is zilika's
plan to gain more visibility amongst its
competition
and this actually leads me to an another
point um which i haven't actually have
written down but it just sort of reminds
me of the top of my head a lot of the
questions that came through were with
regards to your marketing so a lot of
the community for whatever reason then
they're not necessarily happy about the
marketing so
i'd also like you to tell me what your
marketing plans are
sure
so look um first thing is uh i do feel
that there is a lot of there's a lot of
noise in the space
and and you have to filter know you know
you have to fill the facts out of that
noise in many ways
uh just to give an example right um
you know when we launched uh our decks
self swap and we launched i mean
which is the team that's building this
they launched the the decks
when i was interacting with the
community it was very apparent to me
that many people in the silica community
obviously the whole ether and the old
bitcoin but they had never used unison
before they had never used curve before
they had never used one inch before
and that made me think that there are
definitely a lot of people
in the ethereum space today
who hold if they even hold probably 15
20 other assets
but they are they have never used any
single gap on ethereum
and that's mind-blowing because then all
you're doing is you're selling tokens
and not doing nothing else
and that needs to change so our approach
has been to be able to sort of improve
upon that so and and we saw that result
very quickly for example in zlswap case
uh i was quite surprised to see that uh
the number of people the number of
unique addresses
interacting with zil swap on a daily
basis which probably four times higher
than the number of people interacting
with
you know curve which is a stable coin
decks on ethereum
and that gives you a sense that uh
there's a huge gap between
you know projects being used and
projects being being you know in the
news all the time
and our our you know focus has always
been to attract more and more people and
convert these token holders into users
in some way
and i'm glad that in looking at the
numbers it's very clear to me that
that's happening
now uh
now coming back to the to the marketing
sort of angle you know marketing is a
very broad term and
in
in the blockchain community one because
it is it's something that everyone seems
to understand
uh you know it's very difficult for
people to understand starting is very
difficult for people to understand a
pollinate hack but it's it's easy to see
the impact of marketing very very very
quickly
i still remember the days you know a
couple of uh you know when
in in i would say in 2017 or rather in
2018 we had seen um you know ethereum
and bitcoin going really down up to a
point where there was trading at around
100 or 200 at some point
uh there was a lot of chatter in the
ethereum community as well and say look
we need to build uh marketing dolls to
be able to you know push ethereum's
narrative and push
ethereum's uh you know benefits and
attract more people towards ethereum
and i do feel that um there is uh if you
look at the metrics and there are
different metrics you can measure
marketing right you could look at your
committee growth so you could look at
how many people are new people are
joining your
twitter community how many new people
are joining the reddit community and
that has constantly been increasing
and then there is angle of this price
and exposure right which is of course
when the price goes up everyone wants to
see and wants to be a part of that
ecosystem that's built that's being uh
you know marketed
so there's a lot of effort being put
into in from different angles one
obviously around making sure that the
theme the silica committee that that we
have around across telegram twitter
reddit keeps on expanding and our
numbers show that it does uh is is it
indeed expanding we have seen
in literally in the last six to eight
months the number of projects being
built on silk has grown tremendously you
know uh you know so after zoo swap we
have seen more than 20 45 projects being
built over a period of one week or two
weeks
and that's a sign that there are people
who are interested in building unzelican
through that uh it comes there comes the
network effect because once you have a
project building on silica
that creates the own network effect they
have their own ecosystem and that
creates a much broader narrative
of course you know we are also we know
where we lack
we know where uh we can improve and one
area is of course influential marketing
that's something that we have to focus
on and that's why we are here
yeah absolutely um we also have a lot of
conversation about solana uh i mean just
you don't need to answer this straight
away but i mean somebody just said you
know look what solana are doing that
they're doing better marketing
apparently but just in terms of solana
um this will be yeah in terms of solana
someone is asking don't you think solana
has taken advantage um or has taken the
advantage that zilliqa has not in terms
of technology but in terms of adoption
and projects built on it how do you
intend to reclaim this advantage so do
you think your advantage has been taken
yeah so look um literally i think uh
yesterday someone said uh oh solano has
a hundred x more dabs than silicon
that's not true yeah you know that's not
true uh and then i said look this is not
true and then it's okay maybe i put an
extra zero there
and and even that's not true uh you know
it's it's it's of course it's about
visibility it's about exposure but if
you if you count the number of daps if
you count the number of users select
actually stands at number five number
seven in terms of blockchain that's
actually being used today
and what i've been what i mean by being
used
is a number of people who are
interacting with the dapps today on
silica number of people who are
you know who are who are sending
transactions on silica and the number of
transactions that the network processes
on a daily basis i'm not talking about
the capacity the network can process but
the network i'm talking about the the
the number of transactions that network
receives on a daily basis and that's
quite high so if you look at those
numbers it's very clear that you know
zelika stats are number five number
seven across all across all platforms
out there
so yes uh you know there could be uh and
this some that we have been working on
to to improve the exposure
but uh in terms of advantage i think we
have seen that a lot of you know
ethereum for example it does it does
around a million transactions per day
today
uh and and it's very clear that uh
dynasty and polychain
polygon do a little bit more right now
but uh most chains out there they do no
more than four thousand to five thousand
transactions per day
and that's the sad reality and zelika
actually does much better so um i do
feel that yes there is there could be
some work around marketing
but if you look at the real numbers uh
zilliqa is not far behind uh behind many
other chains out there including
including some of the popular ones out
there
so just as a last final question for you
um what is zilika's vision and what is
the main thing that you are trying to
achieve and by which point do you think
that could happen look again i've
probably said this a couple of times but
i do feel that
there is a huge
gap between token holders and end users
so there are token holders who have
never used any of the dapps and i'm
talking about
ethereum even ethereum you know token
holders so it's very clear to me that
there is there needs to be change you
need we need to build products that
these token holders can actually go and
use because in this you can't have
a platform which has a million token
holders but five users there's no point
in building such a change you need to be
able to have convert your token holders
into users
uh so in ethereum's case roughly
speaking around one percent of i mean
less than outside one percent of token
holders actually are users
silica on the other hand even though it
has a much smaller community compared to
the computer ethereum the conversion
rate is actually much higher to around
five percent
and the idea is to push that even even
further so i think if we can and this is
kind of our mission is to able to
convert our token holders into users and
again i think it's not just should be
our our mission but should be i think
generally speaking should be the mission
of of the entire space
uh
space where we have to not just say okay
look here's the token you can invest in
and then uh you know put your you know
assets and
binance or some exchange audio or your
ledger wallet and then forget about
what's happening on the chain we need to
be able to build apps that are easy for
people to use for example if you look
if you look at uni swap and and make a
dial
if you're not deep into ethereum space
you need to be have to watch a one hour
video from your favorite influencer to
be able to use that
use that dab you can't just download
like a
traditional app you can't just go an app
store download that app and be able to
use it you can't do that today and that
complexity has to go and there's
something that we're trying to focus on
as well
yeah i think
that user experience is the most
important thing in this community um you
know having a real use case behind
tokens um you know i certainly agree
with you it took me a while to wrap my
head around you know uni swap and
pancake swap and even the i've been
using the bridge between ethereum and
binance recently and you know it takes
time to wrap your head around these
things so i think making that user
experience as easy as possible is so so
important um so yeah no absolutely and
i'm excited to see how it goes but amer
i want to thank you so much it's been
such a pleasure um having you and having
you on the show i know it's been such a
while since you've spoken so it's been
very educational for me to see where you
guys are up to thank you very much for
inviting me over
yeah absolute pleasure and i want to
thank everybody for tuning in um you
have a very interesting community i've
been reading the live chats um there's a
lot of jokes in there so it's been
amazing to see how that goes so yeah
thank you everybody for tuning in and
america thank you so much for coming on
thank you very much have a good day
[Music]
[Applause]